sometimes the competition is too close
for comfort
in this case wind farms demand for
electricity from conventional generators
like this gas fired plant is decreasing
and there's a simple reason for that
Germany's Renewable Energy Act
stipulates that green energy be fed
first into power grids the frequent down
times at the plant are a source of
increasing frustration for the man in
charge
Bob Dean Viana in tark
sometimes it's for one day but one time
it was for a week it depends on current
developments but the general trend is
now less energy coming from conventional
power stations when there's not enough
wind to power the nearby turbines this
gas fired plant also has the task of
stepping in to bridge that shortage
local utility providers have injected
450 million euros in such plants in the
region around ham but the investment is
proving fruitless the market price for
the end product energy is too low while
that for natural gas continues to rise
jesus' I'm Adonis this is a modern power
station it has to cover interest and
repayment we're unable to generate those
components find the returns posted the
plant is not operating often enough and
the returns are too low amok too tedious
right sue billing deco-inspired favor in
other words a combination of excessive
costs and insufficient activity and the
future looks no brighter the
government's energy policy envisions
around 80% of electricity coming from
renewables by 2050
good news for producers of renewable
power like Greenpeace energy and as they
see it power station operators have had
plenty of time to adapt to the changes
in a transition phase and that requires
smart management as much renewable
energy as possible and as much
conventional energy as necessary these
conventional sources have to earn a
certain amount of money to be able to
continue operating but companies are
trying to generate as much as possible
instead of just meeting demand a mr.
earn as much as possible by do not reach
office in Sofia gets removed Christopher
Dean some power providers are
threatening to shut down their plants
but in fact the authorities have the
final say on shutdowns the federal
network agency has so far received 15
applications which are still pending
DW asked the agency for more details and
got this reply if the federal network
agency concludes that a plant is
indispensable for secure grid operation
it will be prohibited from shutting down
the gas-fired power station in ham is on
the edge of the Ruhr Valley Germany's
industrial heartland the region has a
high demand for energy electricity
providers are upping the pressure and
warning about the potential for
disruptions to the power supply this
gift movement and instance we're seeing
more and more power grid outages as old
power stations reach the end of their
natural working life that will mean
fewer on the market and that could very
well lead to power outages assigning
Posse - what Sol industrial Fazal come
or is it all a bluff the operator is
demanding financial support from the
government to keep the plant in reserve
even if it's not online and delivering
electricity
you